is bruce willis still a star or has his
career died hard
the razzies can't contain they're
disdain for john mcclane
on the one hand bruce willis starred in
so many movies that he will have the
honor of his own special category at an
awards show this year the bad news the
award show is the razzies because all
eight of his movies were so bad they
made john travolta sigh with relief
the razzies are for the worst pictures
of the year michael loftus has a
mantelpiece full of trophies
the category titled the worst
performance by bruce willis in a 2020
movie we'll see bruce willis battle it
out with bruce willis for his most
regrettable mistake sounds like cat
looking through a camera roll after a
night out
yes oh that was good the movies include
out of death which received a zero
percent rating on rotten tomatoes and
midnight in the switchgrass it not only
received terrible reviews but also bears
responsibility for megan fox meeting
machine gun kelly making it impossible
for the rest of us to ever feel safe
opening the internet without the risk of
throwing up all over ourselves
tyrus i think this is a tribute to bruce
willis the man works
all right so bruce willis got his start
he was a struggling bartender yeah and
he like tripped and fell into
moonlighting right moonlighting yeah and
then no one else wanted
die hard yeah so his whole career he's
he's beat the odds and he's working in a
time when an old white man is literally
poisoned
so if i was i'd be like kiss my ass i
made eight movies during a pandemic yeah
sure they're not great we were all doing
it from six feet apart you know what i'm
saying like leave them alone i just love
how people who don't get to do things
criticize people who are doing things
you don't like this movie don't watch
you want to get rotten tomatoes they
said dave chappelle's special was
terrible you know what i'm saying like
rotten tomatoes and anybody else who has
issues the man's working he's a legend
he's been able to he's he's a household
name
feel better and mel gibson leave mel
gibson alone too just want to make a
note to the viewers do not have sex with
rotten tomatoes uh that will lead to
infection and you'll probably die from
experience from experience thank god
there was a very brave of you to say
that yeah thank you thank you good job
thank you for your service thank you and
thank you for the tomatoes
you know um
does willis even care
no it's one he maybe thinks about this
for not even one tenth of one tenth of a
second he laughs and laughs and laughs
meanwhile the people who who started
like what is this the razzies or
whatever they're all like film school
people who don't have careers their
claim to fame is i started the razzies
and every night they're like i hope
bruce willis shows up and then we'll get
on tv do they have a uh they don't have
an actual ceremony do they they do yes
they do he's hosting yeah
but really bruce willis he's one of
those guys he just gets a pass for life
you know you when you when you do die
hard and you do uh pulp fiction yeah and
that a sense sixth sense yes here's a
fun hollywood game what pretend like you
didn't understand the ending okay
whenever you go
it's so much fun just to watch the heads
explodes so wait a minute why couldn't
he open the door i don't get it wait who
is dead oh it's hilarious all right
we'll do that uh when this show's over
cash
um i like some of these movies he's only
in for a little bit he got this he just
knows collect a paycheck show up gone he
probably did these he probably did one a
month
fifth element you remember that one oh
great yeah right great film guy probably
banged 15 mil yeah that girl was the
girl was wearing the duct tape cat yeah
what is going on in your brain regarding
this topic make it sound i'm glad you
clarified yes
uh
i don't know like i don't i don't know i
just you know this i don't know how many
people like these things i don't watch
movies i don't tvs movies are too much
commitment they're too long
uh i mean i guess it's i think it's
great because he's so famous he gets his
own category only because he's so famous
or else no one would get it so we can
see he should just see it as when but
i'm sure he doesn't care
not even a joke in your answer no i
don't have a joke in my answer uh i
should take one more time i'll take yeah
i'll take more time next time like
michael loftus and i'll come prepared
a notebook full of materials oh it's
some shade you asked for a joke you got
it there you go that was a [ __ ]
good nice little roast at the end it's
okay michael thank you for die hard mr
willis thank you
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else